[Music]
mask wearing it's going to be a part of
our lives for the foreseeable future and
as our temperatures start to skyrocket
so too will the outbreaks of mask knee
but don't fret there are some steps you
can take to tackle it
we caught up with senior medical advisor
dr nancy shannon of nurex
it's a telemedicine company that just
launched acne treatment in addition to
its other services
after surveying 1 000 of its patients
found 65 percent have developed mask
knee or mask
acne breakouts from wearing a face mask
it's caused of course by having that
saturated air under your mask settle on
your skin
plus the friction of the mask clogging
your pores here's what she suggests you
do to tackle it
you use a nice gentle cleanser on your
skin at least twice a day um
and by gentle i mean not just a standard
soap but something that's
that's labeled as a genital skin
cleanser
and uh that helps uh keep down the
bacteria that that grows on the skin
and also you want to keep your mask
really clean
yes indeed she also says you want to
moisturize your skin with a
non-comedogenic moisturizer this will
help reduce the friction of the mask
against your skin
and use a benzoyl peroxide wash to help
unclog your pores
hey if that doesn't work might be time
to look at a prescription or topical
medication provided by a company like
nurex